i think i've heard you say it's not
about selling a screenplay
it's about getting the movie made yes
yes how how are those two things
different well i mean
you you could sell screenplay if you
want to make some money
and that's great but you know the in my
mindset it's like
if i love this script and i want to get
made i not only want to get paid but i
want to get it made
because in the the long term you know
sure you make some money but you know
the reason a lot of us are doing this is
to create things
so you know if it's a document that's
just sitting there you know in a drawer
not many people gonna see it but if it's
on netflix or something you can get out
of the world
so yeah i try to like be very focused on
like how do i get a movie made
but i also have a personality where once
i start getting into some i i won't let
it go until
you know and just push and push and push
the movie rage which we did with nick
cage
that movie took five years to get made
you know and it was like a five-year
like hall of constantly working
and pushing it up the hill one time
antoine fuqua actually often
optioned the script he was going to
direct it and that would have been
fantastic
and then we had this other director and
other people were involved one time
ethan hawk was going to be the movie it
just kept
falling apart and getting put together
but you know
we had to have that tenacity of like all
these setbacks the script's too good not
to get made
you know and and a lot of people said
it's a great script it's too bad it
didn't get made
you know so i'm like okay well it's
gonna get made and it took us five years
to get it made
and it finally got made but it's it's
just a different kind of mindset of like
you know if you want to be in the film
business obviously the end
game is to get movies made you know the
flip side of that which is kind of like
strange is that sometimes you can get
hired to write a tv pilot that never
gets made and you make a lot more money
than a film that does get made
you know so you have to kind of temper
that like
don't get me wrong i'm a capitalist and
i love getting paid
but i also want to get a movie made and
completed and finished
so were you always like this were you
wanted to see something through
to the end yeah i'm very good so you
know i'm also i'm working on not being
miserable until it's finished you know i
have a bad habit of like not enjoying
the process which i've got much better
at the last few years
but it's kind of a mindset like you have
to just be focused on like
the the finish line and not let go you
know until it's done because
movie a million things can go wrong even
even after you shoot it
everything can go wrong in post you know
you could run out of money
things could go you know sideways the
editor
does a bad job you know we had a
director on a film
we had a fire in post and i had to do
the sound mix
and the other producer had to do the
color timing so and we had to reshoot
the beginning
so it's a it's a process but we got the
movie finished
so let's take that screenwriter though
that is that first screenplay that's
he's writing about his uncle his uncle
has a pawn shop and he just he's the
coolest guy everybody needs to see this
film at what point do you tell that
person
and and they have this tenacity i don't
think it's gonna work
yeah um that's a good question um but
they have to also kind of like
have some self-reflection of like what
is this script doing for producers like
at the end of the day every movie is
made for one reason
it's not a creative endeavor it's to
make money i mean
secondarily it's creative endeavor but
you know you have to make money unless
you find some rich uncle who's
a billionaire just wants to throw tax
shelters at you you know
that's a whole different story but you
know if it's not working
that script what's wrong with that
script is there not a market for it does
it do producers not you know
you know have you know do they not get
sparked to it
what is the thing that's going to get
you to the to the next level you know if
that script's not working
write another script you know write
something maybe more commercial write
something more
you know personal what what is not
connecting with people on that
script because the thing is what i hear
from agents and managers all the time is
like
99 of scripts i get are horrible you
know people pitching them things or
horrible ideas
and it's like if you write some if you
write well and you have a great script
it will get noticed it might not get
made you might not get money but you'll
get some kind of notice on it but
what is the level of that good script is
it did you spend three months on it
did you spend two years and keep
rewriting the same script over and over
sometimes things don't work i i mean i
don't know on my computer the other day
i found
probably 40 scripts that were half
written
or the first act and i'm like okay it's
not working
it didn't come out the way i thought it
was and i don't see how it's going to be
great to sell
i actually have two full scripts right
now i've written that like
i thought were going to be great i'm
like i don't know they're not what i
want to put out right now
so i just put them away maybe i'll come
back them later maybe i'll never even
look at them again
but if you want to work as a
professional writer and work all the
time
that's what you've got to do is just
keep
you know grow one script isn't going to
make a career
you know so follow-through is great
tenacity
but at some point having some type of an
awareness
that when you're getting notes or you're
just getting just complete rejection
that there's a sign there yes yes okay
and you know sometimes it's good
like if you're working on something
that's not working people are not you
know
you know having any kind of reaction to
it try something else
you know put it away write another kind
of script you know see what people feel
i mean the problem is too a lot of
people give scripts to their friends
and ask their opinion they just go
that's great you know or or even people
who don't know
a script from you know don't work in the
film business you which that's kind of
like a problem too it's like you know i
know a lot of people
subscribe to these like you know they
pay for uh
coverage or they pay for script notes
and you know who's giving you those
script notes somebody who's never worked
on a movie
you know maybe they know a little bit
more about you so you have to be very
careful those things can be very
educational and can help
but you i don't i don't ever like when
people spend a ton of money on those
things
you know because i feel like they're
getting ripped off at some point
because if you want to learn how to make
a movie the template's there
there's hundreds of thousands of movies
on netflix you can watch that have been
made
you just have to find movies like what
you want to do you know if you want to
write a personal story
you know or story about you know you and
your friends and some girl dumped you
watch swingers the template's there it
doesn't have to be the same story
but you can follow the beats and you can
see how you know
it flows and where you you know the
second act turn happens and where the
resolution comes in and what's the arc
it's it's all been done for you
i'm making it sound really easy aren't i
well
some people are self-aware and some
people aren't so yeah have you ever paid
for script coverage
have you ever no you've never i've never
read a book about how to write
screenplay or anything
but i found that i work
a lot of intuition but i also but what i
do though
sometimes and even now that i've been
doing this i'm in the writers guild i've
done it for a long time make a living at
this
even recently i pulled up a script for a
film because i wanted to do
i was thinking about a spy idea that was
very similar i found the script online
i put the movie on on amazon prime and
followed the script with the movie i
don't need to do that but i did it
anyway just to
follow the beats and and you know see
what got shot what then that's a great
exercise for people because sometimes
the script you can see what's in it and
what's not
but i'm like this has already been done
for me it's a different story i have a
completely different idea of a different
story but
this spy movie was awesome so i'm just
going to watch
you know where all the beats happen and
the the formula's there cause
you know making a film is like a pop
song it's there in the box it's two
hours long or
90 minutes to two hours you know you're
not reinventing the wheel
you